I want to talk about something that all
the kids are really talking about
they're not talking about who you loves
but they are talking about Craigslist
yes a lot of people in our audience use
Craigslist and I thought once again I'd
help my audience and I'm talking about
the members of the audience that have a
sale or a connection that they want to
make by showing some of their craigslist
ads right here on the show
[Applause]
older dude who gets it looking for young
cool peeps let's do the do and rock out
to current bands like the spin-doctors
respectable father and businessman seeks
all photos taken when he was still doing
porn for hire me the medium Lebowski
old-fashioned guy seeks old-fashioned
girl with colonial-era strap-on
tired of not being on fire then let me
light you on fire
[Music]
wanted any shirtless photos of Morley
Safer
and finally school seeks busty female
principal why is school in quotation
marks because I'm just talking about my
garage works for me
[Applause]